bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre ce matin sur
notre antenne
les travaux de la commission d' enquête
sur l'évasion fiscale qui a poursuivi
cette semaine à ces auditions
deux jours après à l'assemblée générale
de publicis les sénateurs entendent et
son pdg maurice lévy dont le super bonus
de 16,2 millions d'euros a récemment
fait polémique
tout de suite donc à l'audition de
maurice lévy bonne matinée à tous chers
collègues nous accueillons monsieur
maurice lévy président directeur général
de publicis mais surtout aujourd'hui
président l'association française des
entreprises privées
c'est à dire les principales entreprises
du cac 40 et donc qui sont directement
liés à l'attractivité de la bourse de
paris comme nous venons de le voir je
vous rappelle monsieur le président
directeur général que conformément aux
termes de l'article 6 de l'ordonance du
17 novembre 58 relatives au
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires votre audition doit se
tenir sous serment et que tout faux
témoignage est passible des peines
prévues aux articles 134 tirs et 13 400
34-15 du code pénal en conséquence je
vais vous demander de prêter serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
pour ce faire vous devrez la main droite
et vous dirais-je de jus ce que je vous
invite à faire je le jure je vous
remercie
je vous propose de commencer de cette
audition par un exposé liminaire en
fonction des
question qui ont déjà été fournis par le
rapporteur puis de répondre directement
aux questions de notre rapporteur
monsieur éric bocquet et puis je
passerai ensuite la parole
d'autres membres de la commission vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
président toute petite correction si
vous le permettez je ne suis pas le
président directeur général de publicis
groupe je suis le président du
directoire c'est une société à conseil
de surveillance et donc mes pouvoirs
sont limités et ne sont pas tout à fait
les mêmes que ceux de la président
directeur général je le dis juste pour
ordre
s'il s'agit de dire la vérité au temps
de lire également sur le titre nous
n'ont cessé c'est pas un coin s'est tue
comme les société à conseil de
surveillance et directoire sont peu
nombreuses par extension de manière
générale je suis appelé président
directeur général monsieur j'apporte la
précision et je tiens aussi à préciser
si vous le permettez que je suis pas du
tout un spécialiste de la fiscalité et
que fort heureusement pour moi je ne
connais rien à la fraude sauf pour la
chasse et quand je la trouve au sein du
groupe publicis
et donc si la commission evasio des
capitaux et des actifs hors de france et
c'est un 10 ans des incidences fiscales
a pour objet d'enquêté sur la fraude
fiscale
je crois qu'il est important que je
précise au titre de la fep que de mon
point de vue et du point de vue des
adhérents de l'afep les grandes
entreprises sont étrangères à la fraude
je vais essayé de m'expliquer là dessus
et que les grandes entreprises sont au
contraire unanime à condamner la fraude
et je peux prendre beaucoup
d'illustrations de code de déontologie
qui existe dans les entreprises mais à
commencer par celui de publicis où nous
avons un code extrêmement clair qui
s'appelle janus place qu'il s'agit d'une
part
de veiller à la direction et à l'éthique
et d'autre part de sanctionner donc des
deux visages et nous avons un certain
nombre d'indications régulière sur ce
que doit être le comportement de nos
collaborateurs à travers le monde
donc il est important de 2,2 clairement
condamné tout amalgame entre fraude et
grandes entreprises
et je tiens à le faire de manière très
claire en quelques mots ce que je vous
propose de faire c'est de définir le
rôle de la feps qui est peut-être pas
très bien connu de parler un instant des
spécificités des enjeux d'avenir des
grandes entreprises
le positionnement des grandes
entreprises soumises à la multiplicité
des impositions dans différents pays et
la fiscalité pour demain avec quelques
pistes
si cela peut vous intéresser d'avoir le
point de vue du président de l'afep
les adhérentes de l'afep qui sont il l'a
fait pour groupe à peu près une centaine
97 ou 98 des plus grandes entreprises et
exerçant leur activité en france les
effectifs employés par ces entreprises à
travers le monde s'élève à 5 8 millions
de personnes
c'est donc quelque chose assez important
pour un chiffre d'affaires annuel de
1500 milliards d'euros et la
capitalisation boursière des entreprises
françaises s'élèvent au 31 décembre 2011
a à peu près 800 milliards d'euros
c'est dire un peu le poids de ces
entreprises
au delà des adhérents de la fep un mot
sur les grandes entreprises qui sont
elles c'est d'abord un acteur
indispensable du tissu économique
français
et si on reprend l'étude insee 2012 ils
jouent les études une c est dénombré 2
millions et 691 1049 entreprises
françaises est parmi ces deux millions
six cent quatre-vingt-onze 1049 217 sont
considérés comme de grandes entreprises
c'est 210 cette entreprise représente 3
millions 986 1077 emploi c'est-à-dire 31
% des effectifs du secteur marchand en
france 62% des dépenses ou
investissements de recherche 33 % de la
valeur ajoutée produite près de 50% du
chiffre d'affaires à l'export un point
aussi important nous avons contrairement
à un autre et économie une sur
représentation des grandes entreprises
parmi les 500 premières entreprises
mondiales
nous sommes devant l'allemagne ce qu'il
faut quand même souligner c'est un des
rares domaines dans lequel nous battons
l'allemagne de manière très claire
enfin et contrairement aux idées reçues
les grandes entreprises sont un
important contributeur aux finances
publiques
le débat sur les prélèvements doit être
recentrée sur l'ensemble des
prélèvements supportés par les
entreprises qui je le rappelle la
totalité des entreprises représente 330
5 milliards d'euros c'est à dire près de
50 % des prélèvements totaux quel est le
rôle de la fin quelle est notre métier
que faisons nous la fep a pour objectif
et pour mission essentielle de faire
valoir la position des grandes
entreprises françaises auprès des
institutions européennes des
organisations internationales et des
pouvoirs publics français
essentiellement dans l'élaboration des
réglementations à caractère horizontal
économie finance fiscalité droit des
sociétés droit
la concurrence propriété intellectuelle
droit de la consommation
réglementation sociale droit du travail
droit de l'environnement etc etc
donc notre but notre mission consiste à
analyser ce qui peut être élaborée à en
discuter avec les membres de la fep et à
rapporter le point de vue et les
positions des manques de l'afep auprès
des différents organes et y compris
d'ailleurs au sénat il nous arrive assez
fréquemment de venir pour exposer le
point de vue des entreprises de façon à
voir où il peut y avoir des zones
d'amélioration
la fep ne collectent aucune information
spécifique ses adhérents nous n'avons
pas cette mission nos analyses sont
fondés sur les données publiées comme
par exemple les documents de référence
d'autres surprises
la feps n'entreprend aucune démarche
sectorielles ou individuelles nous
n'intervenons pas en qualité de conseil
que ce soit sur le plan juridique
fiscale sociale ou environnementale ce
n'est pas notre mission ce n'est pas
notre métier et je tiens à le préciser
c'est le métier d'autres personnes de
métier tout à fait honorable mais que la
fête n'a pas les moyens d'exercer
si on se penche un instant sur les
grandes entreprises de manière générale
elles ont pour vocation de se développer
tant en france qu'à l'étranger
la conquête de nouveaux marchés
étrangers implique d'ailleurs une
implantation locale
nous nous battons elle se bat de manière
générale sur le marché mondial pour
accroître leurs parts de marché le siège
des grandes entreprises est en france
leur décisionnaires sont en france mais
les marchés d'aujourd'hui et de demain
et la sai on peut le regretter pour une
certaine pas sont ailleurs en chine au
brésil en inde et donc leur lieu
d'implantation sont dans ces pays
puisqu'il faut accompagner les clients
et conquérir les marchés locaux si je
prends l'exemple de public
6 nous sommes présents dans plus de 109
pays soit au travers de sociétés que
nous contrôlons soit au travers de
représentation avec des entreprises qui
nous représente cedh équivalent d'une
formule de franchise ou d'affiliation la
france représente aujourd'hui 9% du
chiffre de publicis 91 % de notre
chiffre est réalisé hors de nos
frontières tout l'état major se trouve
en france les clients français c'est à
dire ceux qui sont des sociétés
françaises ne représentent aujourd'hui
et on peut le regretter que 7 % de notre
chiffre 93 % de notre chiffre est
réalisé avec des sociétés qu'il faut
aller conquérir dans le middle west
américain au chili au brésil en inde en
chine en russie etc et nous sommes
d'ailleurs extrêmement vigilants sur le
choix des clients puisque pendant des
années d'ailleurs nous avons refusé de
travailler avec des clients locaux dans
un certain nombre de pays temps nous
n'étions pas assuré de la sécurité des
opérations
quelles sont les motivations d'une
implantation locale le client et locales
il est inséré dans un tissu est dans le
métier que nous faisons nous devons nous
mêmes nous insérer dans ce tissu
culturel et d'ailleurs nous avons comme
mot d'ordre à publicis viva la
différence c dr koné et c'est ce qu'a
fait une partie de la réussite de
publicis nous avons d'emblée reconnu que
la mondialisation devait se faire sur
les différences culturelles et la
reconnaissance culturelle de chacun des
pays et de chacune des régions
et c'est ainsi que nous avons réussi à
battre ce qu'ils proposaient une
homogénéisation qu'on pourrait qualifier
d' américanisation et dans certains cas
cité un exemple nous avions gagné 1
un client extrêmement importante sur
l'ensemble de l'europe et un mot donné
ce client nous a dit écoutez on a besoin
de vos kazakhstan il est désolé
kazakhstan connais pas ou c'est même pas
très bien où c'est sur la carte il dit
c'est pas très compliqué où vous êtes au
kazakhstan vous perdez notre
collaboration et ça a était simple il
fallait immédiatement que nous trouvions
à partenaires au kazakhstan nous ne
sommes pas installés par nous mêmes et
nous avons choisi un partenaire
qu'ensuite nous avons racheté mais c'est
ainsi que nous avons pu maintenir la
collaboration avec ce client et pour
reprendre la signer là l'expression
utilisée par un de nous très grand
client international
quand j'avais été le voir pour lui dire
il nous faut dix ans pour installer le
publicis au plan mondial mais d'y
écouter la mondialisation c'est simple
on y est ou on n'y est pas c'est comme
être enceinte
vous êtes vous n'êtes pas un simple si
vous n'êtes pas mondiale vous nous
intéressait pas et c'est comme ça que ça
se passe
donc nous avons été contraints de suivre
et actuellement nous nous intéressons
bien sûr ajouter un majoritairement au
pays dans lesquels il y a des
possibilités de développement avec des
clients locaux et de croissance pour le
groupe
nous nous implantons localement et cette
implantation locale implique une
imposition locale
nous sommes donc sujet à imposition
locale et conformément d'euros locales
et au droit international d entreprise
par un pays d'impôts sur les bénéfices
du pays dans lequel elles réalisent
leurs bénéfices et en ce qui concerne
les glandes de publicis toutes les
filiales américaines paye sur les
bénéfices ghannouchi tenir l'impôt
fédéral et l'impôt des états et ceux ci
représentent des sommes assez
considérable en chine le groupe paye sur
toutes les transactions entre 5 et 9% de
business taxes il ya une question qui
revient régulièrement entre sur la
notion de
optimisation fiscale autant l'aborder de
manière très claire la fiscalité et est
une charge source d'attention au même
titre que toutes les charges et dans la
perspective du maintien de la
compétitivité de l'entreprise
nous ne faisons pas d'opérations
destinées à faire de l'optimisation pour
de l'optimisation seo clair là dessus
c'est quelque chose qui n'appartient pas
à notre vocabulaire et qui n'appartient
pas à notre façon de faire est en
revanche nous regardons bien entendu
notre taux et et je dois vous dire que
la première fois que j'ai eu à le
regarder je ne savais même pas ce que
c'était je lisais un rapport de
l'analyste qui parlait de lothaire de
publicis ne me dise qu'était ce que
pouvait bien être notre tr la plainte
directeur financier julie mais qu'est ce
que c'est que cette histoire on a noté m
c'est quoi et c'est effective tax wright
c'est à dire quel est le taux effectif
d'imposition et ce taux fait l'objet d'
analyse de tous les analystes financiers
et qui les regardent et qui les compare
si je prends un exemple très simple
notre taux effectif d'imposition est de
l'ordre de 29 %
mon plus grand concurrent que les
britanniques
enfin britannique il n'est plus le
britannique hylas lui la nationalité
britannique il est même sort mais sa
société a déménagé récemment à dublin un
taux de 24 %
il ya donc cinq points d'amélioration de
son résultat simplement par le fait qu'
il a un un taux effectif d'impôt
inférieure
omnicom ça c'était wpp omnicom a un taux
de presque un tiers hypeed gicquel le
concurrent américain de 26% et puis
havas de 23%
la charge d'impôt comptabilisés par le
groupe fait l'objet
et d'un audit régulier annuel par les
commissaires aux comptes et par tous nos
auditeurs nous avons des règles
extrêmement précise et s'est vérifié
aussi bien au plan du contrôle interne
que du contrôle externe
il ya un point très important c'est
qu'en fait pardon de le souligner de
cette façon là et de manière extrêmement
claire mais je crois qu'il faut dire la
vérité toute la vérité s'il existe un
problème de différentiel de taux
d'imposition et s'il existe un à un un
sujet sur ce plan c'est bien parce que
les états se sont organisés pour ça
compris au sein de la communauté
européenne de l'union européenne
donc si on regarde les choses il faut
bien fois il ya des annonces des
placards ont tjrs et qui sont faits par
ces pays pour dire qu'il y avait un
certain nombre d' avantage de
compétitivité que ce soit les routes que
soit le climat les écoles le bien-être
et l'imposition et on a un bon vous vous
le connaissez l'irlande pour prendre cet
exemple bien ça attire et wpp qui était
une société britannique installé à
londres et qui a transféré son siège
social pour des raisons strictement
fiscale et ça a été annoncé comme tel
par le ceo de wpp en disant c'est al
avantage de mes actionnaires
je me dois de le faire et il y a un
certain nombre d'autres cas où il peut
pas dire que cette compétitivité et le
fait d' états laxistes
si je prends l'exemple de l'allemagne
l'allemagne a modifié sa fiscalité et
elle a privilégié une assiette beaucoup
plus large et un taux plus réduit et de
ce fait l alto fédérale sur les sociétés
que la reine est relativement faible
puisqu'il se situe à 15 % le royaume-uni
vient dé nos d'annoncer un peu un plan
sur la réduction des détours des impôts
qui vont passer de 24 en 2011 23 en 2012
à 22 en 2013 et puis ils viennent de
créer c'est intéressant la patate box
qui impose au taux de 10% les redevances
des brèves des brevets donc il est
intéressant de loger des brevets en
grande bretagne puisque c'est dans
l'intérêt de l'actionnaire
quoi qu'il en soit la dimension fiscale
il faut bien le voir pour les
entreprises appartient à l'ensemble des
données qui sont à la disposition d'un
chef d'entreprise quand il doit prendre
une décision pour s'implanter dans un
pays et ils regardent les
infrastructures le système éducatif
les salaires horaires la capacité de
former ou ou de développer la main
d'oeuvre
ce sont les éléments principaux et puis
accessoirement mais seulement
accessoirement des éléments comme la
fiscalité plus important et le regarde
avec attention toute la partie juridique
et social parce que dans certains cas
c'est un fatras difficile pour certaines
entreprises notamment les entreprises
américaines et ne parlons pas des
entreprises chinoises qui elle d'abord
ne parle pas le droit romain et qui en
plus se trouve confronté à un monde qui
leur est totalement étranger
est ce que je voudrais aussi souligner
très rapidement je vous le promets c'est
ce qui se passe dans les pays que j'ai
appelé il ya un peu plus d'un an non
plus émergent b submergeant c'est à dire
ce que l'on appelle généralement les
briques
il faut savoir que il se donne une
certaine liberté par rapport aux règles
de l'os et des oeufs et qu' ils décident
de ré qui n'ont strictement rien à voir
avec ce qui est approuvé et admis par l'
ocde et décide de taxation qui sont en
contradiction avec ti compris les
conventions internationales
alors je vous donnais jeu et par emprunt
reprend tout le détail mais je vous
communiquerai le texte électroniquement
c'est ce que vous m'aviez demandé donc
on le fera mais vous communiquer
deux éléments qui sont quand même très
très intéressant enfin de 3,3 le premier
et non
publicis donc je prends ma casquette
puis 8 6 nous avons tous nos effectifs
de gestion du groupe installé en france
et nous avons ce que nous appelons des
management fils c'est à dire que nous
facturons nos prestations au brésil ou
ailleurs
ewa tous les pays d'ailleurs et de
manière tout à fait cohérente vérifiées
et vérifiables et il faut soumettre
je ne sais combien de documentation à
aux administrations fiscales locales
parce qu'elle ne conteste toujours par
sens que nous pompons les profits
réalisés dans le pays pour alléger la
charge fiscale et que nous les
rapatrions en france donc on doit le
justifier etc
ce sont des prestations techniques qui
sont absolument certaine et qui ne
souffre pas de critique cependant les
les brésiliens ont considéré que ça
méritait à l'impôt à la source
15 % et 25 % d'impôts et de charges
diverses 40% ce qui fait que nous
l'entreprise française
nous recevons que 60% de ce que nous
facturons alors que nous devons recevoir
normalement les 100% je le dis au
passage c'est un élément sur lequel
d'ailleurs puisqu'il s'agit toujours de
parler franchement dans cette commission
on ne reçoit pas beaucoup dette ni de
l'administration ni de l'étang on nous
laisse un peu seul face à ces problèmes
là je vous donne un autre exemple
extrêmement intéressant il ya eu un
contrôle d'une de nos opérations en
chine en chine il ya une taxe business
taxe c'est une taxe sur le chiffre
d'affaires et il faut présenter les fiat
yao
ce sont des documents qui sont un vrai
estampillée etc et on a eu la visite
d'un certain nombre d'inspecteurs qui
sont allé collecter les fameux fier tiao
il ne faut pas trop se trouvait donc ils
nous ont dit il ya là dessus on va vous
taxer on a dit mais attendez laissez
nous collecter les shows non non on vous
taxe et vous pourrez toujours réclamer
la différence et nous on taxe et on a
été obligé de payer autrement nous
retirer la licence on a présenté les
papiers et on nous ait dit à deux faces
vous ne pouvez pas vous ne pouvez pas
pour l'administration ce serait une
perte de face que de revenir en arrière
on a agité tout ce qu'on a pu agiter
l'ambassade de france en chine
l'ambassade de chine en france on a
essayé de faire chaud on n'a pas trouvé
un seul avocat qui était prêt à faire un
procès en cours je m'attaque pas
l'administration fiscale chinoise et
donc nous avons payé de manière
totalement un du tout simplement pour
que une brave administration chinoise ne
perde pas la face
des sommes qui n'ont rien à voir avec ce
qui est normalement dû voilà voilà ce
que il se passe dans un stadium deux
pays je ne vous parlerai pas et je vous
laisserai parce que je vois que j'abuse
de votre temps l'exemple indien mais là
c'est un exemple très connus ou en
contradiction même avec la la décision
de la cour de cassation indienne et la
cour suprême ils ont imposé des
entreprises en disant puisque vous
vendez quelque chose de manière
indirecte en inde nous taxons en inde
même si c'est totalement en indirect est
en contradiction avec toutes les règles
de l'oscd donc on est un petit peu
désarmée quand on se trouve dans ces
situations et on aimerait bien puisque
je suis là et que je suis en train de
témoigner au nom des grandes entreprises
françaises à voir un peu plus souvent le
soutien de l'état français
et pour conclure je vais essayer de
de vous donner quelques pistes
d'amélioration vue du point de vue des
entreprises donc par dont elles sont les
serments frappé au show de l'intérêt des
entreprises
mais l'intérêt des entreprises c'est
aussi l'intérêt de la france puisque
nous savons très bien que la seule façon
qu'on soit plus compétitif et qu'on
réussisse à un créer des activités plus
conséquente en france la fiscalité comme
je le soulignais fait partie intégrante
de la compétitivité des entreprises
elle est d'une façon ou d'une autre
répercutée sur les prix donc de ce fait
plus on est taxé plus à se retrouvent
dans les prix on n'a pas le choix
dans ce contexte c'est la bonne solution
celle qui nous paraît la plus évidente
c'est la convergence et ont tous des cas
si on ne peut pas faire une convergence
et je comprends bien et on n'est pas
complètement idiot on sait très bien
qu'on peut pas avoir une convergence
avec le brésil qu'on peut par une
convergence avec la chine c'est
impossible
en revanche avant une convergence avec
les principaux pays européen et ne pas
se retrouver avec des pays européens de
l'union européenne qui bénéficie des
soutiens de l'europe et qui font
concurrence sur la fiscalité ça cela me
paraît être un élément de base
ça c'est la moindre des solidarités dans
la maison europe et donc je pense que
c'est un élément important en plus
puisqu'on est dans un moment où on parle
beaucoup de nouveaux impôts nous paraît
important que de souligner que nous
avons déjà une charge fiscale plus
importante et plus lourde
nous faisons partie des champions du
monde et que donc tout ce qui du
consisterait à alourdir cette charge
mérite au minimum un double examen et
donc méfions nous des éléments de
fiscalité qui touche aux sièges
d'entreprises et à un certain nombre
d'autres éléments qui sont pénalisants
pour l'entreprise
enfin je pense que il est important
d'analyser tout ce qui se passe sur les
différents pays et surtout il y a deux
ou trois choses que je voudrais
souligner le premier la première c'est
de grâce essayons d'avoir un peu de
sécurité juridique il il est extrêmement
pénalisants qu'on vous avez pris
décision de voir qu'elle est remise en
cause parce que les textes change et
donc tout d'un coup c'est assez
embarrassant pour dire le moins
la deuxième chose évitons la
rétroactivité
on a un peu trop fait appel c'est quinze
dernières années à la rétroactivité ga
même un peu plus que cela
alors qu'il fut un temps où c'était un
territoire sacro saint est extrêmement
respectée ce qu'ils aient été générés
avant ne faisait pas l'objet de
nouvelles taxations et enfin et essayons
comme ça existe un certain nombre de
pays de développer des relations avec
l'administration qui serait empreinte de
l'esprit de collaboration et non pas
d'esprit de méfiance et je pense que si
il y avait cet esprit de collaboration
comme ça existe dans certains pays il
dans certains pays c'est pas seulement
le rescrit guémy qui fait l'objet de
conversations mais c'est même sur
certaines décisions ou dix on s'apprête
à prendre telles décisions que nous
conseillez-vous comment voyez vous les
choses quels sont les risques etc
et donc c'est quelque chose qui serait
extrêmement utile pour le bien de
l'économie française voilà pardon que
j'ai été un peu long mais il y avait
deux casquettes
il fallait donc gens remplissent les
deux sujets la tâche est importante
monsieur le président et il fallait être
complet donc nous avons bien compris le
message
je vais m'excuser parce que je vais me
faire remplacer pape président koné je
reviendrai dans quelques instants
arrive la parole va être donc aux
rapporteurs pour lancer le débat et puis
après vos formes de la commission je
suis à disposition
je suis à disposition de tout le monde
non monsieur rapporteur bien merci
monsieur le président en vient à la
première question s'adressera aux
dirigeants de publicis que vous êtes et
non pas représentants de la fep
vous nous avez présentés dont votre
votre groupe votre activité donc vous
dites être présent dans 109 pays dans le
monde dont j'ai bien noté que vous
évitiez scrupuleusement les paradis
fiscaux
toutefois est ce que vous êtes présent
et y at il des entités publicis présente
dans des territoires à fiscalité
privilégiée dans le monde et en europe
oui mais partout nous sommes nous sommes
avec des activités si je prends un
exemple qui est la russie par exemple en
russie
l'impôt et à 20% nous avons près de 1000
personnes 900 et quelques très
exactement si je prends l'irlande nous
avons quelques agences mais qui ne
fonctionne que sur l'irlande c'est à
dire que nous n'avons pas d'extra
territorialité
nous ne sommes pas dans un pays prenons
l'irlande qui servirait des clients en
france en angleterre en allemagne ou
ailleurs
partout nous sommes nous servons des
clients internationaux localement ou des
clients locaux
donc si l'idée est que serait en fait
derrière la question monsieur le
rapporteur
l'idée serait est ce que vous vous
installez dans un pays pour et éviter ou
optimiser la fiscalité
la réponse est non
bien deuxième question alors on a ce
débat régulièrement un peu moins ces
dernières semaines mais dans les
premières auditions de cette commission
le débat revenait régulièrement entre
optimisation et fraude fiscale dont vous
avez expliqué que vous pratiquiez
l'optimisation mais quel serait le jeu
quelles seraient vos yeux la pratique
frauduleuse fiscalement à partir de quel
moment tomberait ton dans la foi dans la
fraude fiscale à vos yeux
non je n'ai pas dit que nous pratiquions
l'optimisation j'ai dit à propos de
l'optimisation laissez-moi souligner ce
que sont les taux je ne pratiquons pas
si l'optimisation consiste à faire des
manips pour parler français
des combinaisons de manière à transférer
des activités réduire les
investissements outre faire des
opérations compliquées etc dont le seul
but est de réduire l'impôt la réponse
est claire nous ne faisons pas ça donc
et je le dis sous serment et donc la
fraude je commencerai à quel moment
qu'elle vaut rien la fraude est très
simple c'est que
quand on fait de manière intentionnelle
une opération pour ne pas payer l'impôt
kids voilà je sais c'est une définition
un peu barbare basique je ne sais pas la
définir juridiquement mais je lai
définie de manière concrète ce serait ça
la fraude donc pas d'entité dans l'est
dans les territoires aux chanceux ce que
vous nous dites clairement nous l'avons
gradins identités n'ont pas de compte
non plus pas trop non plus n'ont pas de
compte et je peux même vous donner un
exemple assez amusant il y a quelques
années nous avons décidé par 4 5 ans de
créer une société financière parce que
nous
nous traitons et énormément d'argent
puisque si notre chiffre d'affaires est
de l'ordre de 6 milliards d'euros
enfin le revenu ceci représente la marge
brute d'autofinancement
le volume d'affaires que nous traitons
est de l'ordre de 60 milliards d'euros
on est une idée en tête et donc quand il
a fallu créer une société financière de
manière à bien gérer les flux financiers
nous nous avons eu des conseils et un
conseil nous a dit bah il faut
l'installer en irlande et j'ai refusé
j'ai refusé j'ai dit non je ne veux pas
installées en irlande et sera installée
en france et pour deux raisons une
raison idiote de patriotisme
d'entreprise
et puis ils raison par rapport à la
suspicion générale me suis dit oh la la
évitons conviennent même nous soupçonné
d'avoir fait quelque chose uniquement
dans ce but là donc les choses sont
d'une grande clarté
je reviens sur les ans que vous avez
cités de ce concurrent britannique qui a
lui choisi précisément des cieux fiscaux
plus cléments
ça va à l'irlande
quel est votre jugement par rapport à
cette démarche par conséquent nous avons
été interrogés à ce sujet y compris par
des actionnaires et nous avons même été
interpellé je dire qu'au moment où ça
s'est passé ça s'est passé il ya
quelques années c'était le gouvernement
brown et le gouvernement brown avait
augmenté la fiscalité pour les sièges et
donc à ce moment-là est certain nombre
d'entreprises britanniques plus ou moins
visibles ont décidé de quitter longue et
je reviendrai d'ailleurs sur un sujet
important elles elles ont décidé de
quitter londres et la société la plus
visible à cause non pas de son poids
mais mais de ce que représente une
entreprise de communication dans le
milieu notre poids est faible par
rapport à total etc
mais nous avons une visibilité qui est
fort compte tenu du fait que nous
travaillons pour des clients mondiaux et
que nous sommes dans l'univers du média
donc il a d'abord dit tout ceci est
publique
il a interpellé le gouvernement disant
si vous faites je partirai le
gouvernement l'a fait que normal et il
est parti et il a justifié sa et il a
fait des assemblées générales
extraordinaires pour le transfert et il
a même fait une opération assez
compliqué puisque il s'est installée
partiellement à dublin et partiellement
à guernesey
je sais pas trop le détail de ces
opérations se mahler assez sophistiqué
et à ce moment là on m'a posé la
question
beaucoup d'investisseurs m'ont demandé
que comptez-vous faire je dis moi je
compte rien faire je pense premièrement
que si nous sommes ce que nous sommes
nous le devons aux pays qui a accueilli
notre développement et qui nous a permis
de nous développer comme n'étions pas
grand chose donc la france et je pense
que il est normal que nous contribuons à
l'effort national donc le dessus
ma position a été d'une grande clarté
vis-à-vis des actionnaires et je lui ai
défendu publiquement
dernière question avant de passer la
parole à ma collègue corinne bouchoux il
me semble si vous avez été l'un des
signataires de l'appel des 16 en 2011
par bora et c'est l'un des signataires
j'ai été à l'origine
à l'origine on pas de l'appel des seize
mais j'ai écrit est effectivement une
tribune dans le monde qui est paru à peu
près simultanément avec celle de
monsieur warren buffet est bien que je
l'avais adressé au monde avant que celle
de monsieur warren buffett et et pris sa
position
ma position avait été très clair à
l'époque et elle est toujours très
claire nous traversons une période
difficile le devons faire des efforts il
est normal que ceux qui payent qui
reçoivent la meilleure part contribuer
davantage et j'appelais à une
contribution supplémentaire de ce qu'ils
étaient comme j'avais dit les mieux
nantis les plus favorisés là dessus le
nouvel observateur a décidé de s'emparer
de ce texte est de faire un appel d des
seize
j'avais hésité à signer cet appel parce
que je n'aimais pas le taxer nous je
n'aimais pas cette approche un peu du
pardon mais vulgaire mais je les signe
est néanmoins parce que je voulais pas
être en contradiction avec le propos que
j'avais tenu et je ne suis pas en
contradiction je suis bien sûr favorable
à une augmentation des impôts
et comme oudi jusqu'à un point jusqu'à
un point sur non c'est pas il faut pas
exagérer il faut pas être confiscatoire
donc jusqu'à un point il faut être ni
confiscatoire n'est décourageant c'est
mon seul propos là dessus donc je suis
très favorable à l'augmentation des
impôts je suis très favorable en ce qui
concerne pour payer davantage d'impôts
je ne suis pas favorable à ce que ce
soit décourageant confiscatoire et
humiliant
si corinne monsieur le président merci
de votre exposé extrêmement pédagogique
est clair moi je vous avais deux
casquettes donc je vais me permettre de
poser une question et de faire une
remarque
ma première question c'est que en
matière de fraude et d'évasion fiscale
il ya la réalité factuelle difficile à
saisir on y travaille depuis des
semaines et la représentation que nous
pouvons nous faire que les acteurs
peuvent se faire que les économies
peuvent se faire de la situation telle
qu'elle est et une députée européenne
que j'ai beaucoup croisé ces derniers
temps me disais il ya un peu de type de
pays qui a beaucoup travaillé sur ces
questions elle me disait il ya deux
types de pays pour aller vite les pays
latins ou le rapport à la norme est un
petit peu flou on va plutôt chercher le
voilà la transgression et puis les pays
nordiques ou dans tout un tas de raisons
historiques culturelles on va être plus
rigide plus strictes et où on peut
supposer que la fraude et l'évasion
fiscale soit sont moins importants
soissons plus réprimés et donc au titre
de vos compétences qui sont grandes dans
le domaine notamment de la communication
des représentations et votre
connaissance des grandes entreprises
françaises
je me demandais comment effectivement on
pouvait faire en sorte que peut-être à
tord ou à raison je suis très prudente
mais l'image d'un certain nombre
d'entreprises en france
et bien pas de la catégorie des pays
latins à la catégorie des pays nantis qu
en terme d'image de vertu c'est ma
première question est ma deuxième
question vous avez je pense que c'était
à dessein donner l'exemple extrêmement
compliqué de la chine où on a un système
qui évoluent tous les six mois nous on
parle d'un système qui évoluent tous les
ans en chine c'est tous les six mois
ça évolue suivant les régions vous
pouvez entamer un processus commercial
avec un système de taux et trois
semaines après on vous l'a changé donc
la chine est un est un maquis et c'est
très compliqué pour autant c'est un pays
qui par des moyens on sur lequel on peut
avoir des réserves lutte de façon très
énergique contre la fraude puisque vous
le savez comme moi la fraude fiscale est
punissable de la peine de mort dans un
certain nombre d'états en chine 2 voilà
comme ça
et donc je voulais savoir votre
réflexion sur effectivement la façon la
plus la plus démocratique et la plus
saine qu'il y avait à faire rentrer les
acteurs économiques d'un système de
transgression vers un système de respect
des normes et de qui limite la fraude et
l'évasion fiscale même si vous l'avez
bien montrer un point de 1.2
différentiel au niveau du taux quand on
travaille sur 60 ou 100 milliards
évidemment un point de plus ou un point
de moins ça fait beaucoup d'argent si on
peut le comprendre
je vous remercie sont deux questions
extrêmement importante
alors en ce qui concerne la chine parce
que c'est rapide tout et insécurité tout
on peut nous retirer l'autorisation
d'exercer le lendemain c'est d'une
fragilité juridique excessive
il y à des transgressions sur le droit
de propriété intellectuelle industriels
etc
enfin je veux dire que la liste est
longue et je n'arrive pas à comprendre
qu' on ne puisse pas en discuter avec
les chinois gelé j'ai évoqué ce problème
je sais que ça n'a pas été très
appréciée publiquement auprès de wen
jibao je fais partie du world economic
forum il se trouve que nous avions une
session privée privée il y avait 200
personnes avec le premier ministre et je
lui ai expliqué la situation est
effectivement il a pris des positions
comme sable faire ça ordinaire rigueur
etc
le résultat c'est que alors c'est aussi
compliqué par le fait qu'il ya les
provinces il ya les régions il ya l'état
et que il décède un maquis extrêmement
compliqué et il y a encore un système
féodal pardon pour l'expression de
gouvernement donc je peux pas en dire
beaucoup plus sur la chine mais mais ce
n'est pas si on peut se baser que sur ce
plan là et s'il n'y avait pas cette
croissance exceptionnelle et si nous
n'avions pas tous nos clients qu'elle
est là je ne suis pas certain que nous y
serions allés si rapidement je me
rappelle quand j'avais 10 ans marcel
bleustein blanchet au début des années
il va falloir y aller il me dit tu es là
encore oui est-ce que vous parler
chinois
sinon j'ai pas besoin de parler chinois
n'en parlez pas chinois je comprenais ce
qui voulait dire c'est à dire vous
n'avez pas la mentalité chinoise
bon donc voilà c'est une situation qui
est effectivement préoccupantes si on
regarde maintenant l'aspect pays latins
pays
saks anglo saxons là il y a beaucoup à
dire et le vous allez me pardonner mais
je vais commencer par le premier
coupable quel état les différents
gouvernements qui se sont ensuite
poursuivies depuis des décennies papa
disant pas 15 ans pas 20 ans et qui ont
d'abord éviter de parler de payeurs de
taxes et qui parle de contribution et
qui essayent d'ailleurs de masquer et
qui explique qu'il faut sortir des gens
de l'assiette et que c'est pas bien de
payer l'impôt donc on sort des gens de
l'assiette parce que c'est bien
socialement
au lieu de dire qu'il est bon
socialement même si c'est une toute
petite contribution de l'élargir et de
montrer que c'est un devoir
or là il y a une espèce de deux volontés
mais toutes les lois enfin toutes les
lois pas tout mais de très nombreuses
lois déclarations du ministre des
finances à la télévision ou du président
la république
cette année est déjà un million de
contribuables en moins et on s'en
réjouit
non évidemment quand on dit ça on
provoque nécessairement le fait que
contribuer n'est pas bien puisqu'on
l'essor de la contribution
il aurait été de loin préférable de dire
bon il faut aider ceux qui ne peuvent
pas contribuer donc idéal petite
assiette
il ya une petite actes et puis ceux qui
n'ont pas les moyens on les aide par de
la redistribution c'est tout le système
de redistribution qui fonctionne si bien
en france et donc
c'est le premier élément deuxième et
dément ce qui concerne les grandes
entreprises
je voudrais là-dessus à être très clair
il faut savoir que nous sommes scrutés
finalistes
nous sommes scrutés de manière
épouvantable si vous pouviez lire les
rapports d'analystes qui sont faits sur
les grandes entreprises mais on épluche
tout tout ce que l'on fait comment est
ce qu'on fait comment est ce qu'on fait
une commère toutes les questions qui
nous sont posés les c'est laid il est
impressionnant de voir jusqu'où va le
détail des questions qui nous sont
posées j'ai été obligé de m'informer sur
la tonne équivalent carbone par personne
pour pouvoir répondre à des questions
d'investisseurs alors que je pensais que
nous étions assez éloigné de ses
préoccupations puisque nous n'avons pas
d'usinés nous générons pas de gaz à
effet de serre etc
j'ai découvert que si le simple fait de
respirer d'avoir des collaborateurs et
quelque chose devra avoir moins de
collaborateurs
parce que plus j'ai des collaborateurs
plus j'ai des tonnes équivalent pétrole
dans ce domaine et le carbone donc on
est scrutée de manière extrêmement
détaillée on est analysé dans le détail
et les grandes entreprises celles qui
sont cotées et celles qui font appel aux
capitaux étrangers aux investisseurs
internationaux
celles là sont soumises à la question de
manière très rigoureuse et ce n'est pas
bon et ce n'est pas appréciée de tricher
et ce n'est pas bon et ce n'est pas
apprécié de ne pas être extrêmement
strict et rigoureux
donc il y a un comportement qui est
d'une rigueur importante je ne suis pas
en train de dire qu'ils quittent que
tout le monde je peux pas délivré 1 1
ni un carton rouge ni un carton vert jeu
mais je sais de manière générale c'est
cela la situation de nos entreprises et
aussi longtemps que l'on ne sera pas en
france
trouver des réponses au manque de
capitaux on sera dans une situation
extrêmement fragile il se trouve que 1
un investisseur est une association nous
en poser la question des de la manière
dont les capitaux de publicis était
détenu le capital de publicis était
détenu et malheureusement ce n'est pas
très différent des entreprises du cac 40
59 % de nos capitaux sont détenus par
des investisseurs étrangers
et heureusement que nous avons encore la
famille
les salariés qui détiennent une part du
capital autrement ou serait plutôt à 65
ou ce sont 10 % donc pour eux sur les
grandes entreprises le problème se pose
peut enfin il ya un dernier point qui
paraît intéressant et qui devraient être
explorées c'est que depuis là encore de
très nombreuses années ont fait peser
l'impôt sur un nombre de plus en plus
petit soit d'entreprise soit d'individus
et la base se restreint et donc la
pression augmente et 2 se fait voilà
l'assiette se restreint et de ce fait
vous avez pas mal de gens qui cherchent
les moyens d'éviter de payer l'impôt
la conclusion est simple on a intérêt à
élargir la base et c'est ce qui se passe
dans tous les pays et il y a partout un
peu de fraudes mais elle est extrêmement
j'ai l'impression et c'est d'ailleurs
même les médias parfois ne rendent pas
service puisque un moment donné je me
rappelle d'un un article le sport
national favori des français
la fraude fiscale quand on dit que c'est
un sport favori sport national je trouve
que là aussi on est quasiment en train
de dire que vous avez tous les trucs 1
vous avez tout à toutes les occasions et
des numéros spéciaux comment éviter
comme entre eux et vous avez des gens
qui explique on est combien de fois nous
sommes sollicités par des entreprises
des conseils qui viennent nous voir en
nous disant on peut réduire la base
fiscale de publicis etc
nous évitons que cela ait
personnellement je les évite à titre
personnel merci monsieur le président
j'ai bien apprécié monsieur le président
vos discours sur l'étroitesse voulue par
les responsables politiques de nos
assiettes fiscales et pour vous sourire
j'ai appartenu à majorité n'est pas
qu'il ya un monsieur qui est supprimée
liesse f en quatre
entre 86 88 et la contrepartie c'est que
nous enlevions deux millions de
contribuables sur les bas revenus est
celui qui a pris la décision il a
toujours pensé que d'avoir supprimé 17
craie et vannes aux élections vous dire
que les deux millions n'ont pas été
d'une très grande reconnaissance
apparemment en plus en plus ce sont des
erreurs politiques la plupart du temps
non seulement économiques et fiscales
plus sérieusement veut nous sommes en
fait à travers ces mots si on réfléchit
aussi à son dossier est plus ou moins
voisin collatéraux est ce que vous
pensez pas qu aujourd'hui la principale
richesse finalement est-ce que la
fiscalité devrait peut-être privilégiés
se sont plus fait dans le grand débat
que nous avons sur la
réindustrialisation du pays
donc tout le monde veut ré
industrialiser le pays
moi je suis de ceux qui pensent que nos
vraies valeurs si aujourd'hui plutôt les
brevets les propriétés industrielles et
marc marchetti nexterra et qu'en fait la
production à des coups qui font que
certains régions du monde aujourd'hui
sont dans la concurrence imbattable pour
des raisons de régimes sociaux et à ce
que tout le monde connaît et nike et
adidas ce qui fait la différence et
marketing
parce que de façon c'est fabriqué au
même endroit ou à peu de choses près
alors est ce que vous ne pensez pas qu
une fiscalité qui prédit gérer un peu
ses valeurs
plus ou moins corporelle n'aurait pas un
intérêt plus pour attirer à nouveau les
chercheurs les industriels et tout et
tout ça et tout ce qui en fait on passe
le cap de la simple production et vous
aviez tout à l'heure l'intervention de
jean-pierre juillet il se trouve qu'avec
jean pierre jouyet nous avons co signé
un rapport et c'est un des rares rapport
auquel j'ai contribué qui a vu plus de
80% de ces propositions appliquée
c'est le rapport sur l'économie de
l'immatériel et alors que j'ai participé
à deux autres commissions dont l'une sur
la lutte contre la toxicomanie qui est
allé au cimetière des rapports des
différentes commissions et donc le
problème de l'immatériel et de
l'économie de l'immatériel est un
problème sur lequel je m'étais beaucoup
penché bien avant ça et c'est pour ça
que j'avais été choisi pour travailler
avec jean pierre sur ce sujet qu'est ce
que on avait des gages à l'époque
effectivement et vous avez 100% raison
c'est un un des points sur lesquels nous
pouvons non seulement créer de la
richesse
mais créer des emplois à forte valeur
ajoutée et favoriser le développement
deux filières de d'intelligence deux
moyens qui sont susceptibles de créer de
véritables pôles de développement
si on se penche uniquement sur le
problème de l'économie du numérique
vient à d'autres jeux d'hier publicis et
est un exemple d'entreprise de
l'économie de l'immatériel
nous faisons que ça hein je n'ai pas un
seul ouvrier et donc c'est comme ça que
ça se passe et tout ce que nous
fabriquons ce sont des prototypes rien
d'autre et si on regarde le secteur que
s'est il passé
le premier moteur de recherche au monde
a été créé par les français la première
plateforme au monde pour des enchères a
été créée par les français et je
pourrais continuer pourquoi est ce que
ces français qui ont été suffisamment
géniaux pour inventer cela et il faut
souligner je pas être personnel mais
j'ai fait une partie de mes études aux
états unis et j'ai mes trois fils qui
ont fait des études aux états unis après
avoir fait les grandes écoles françaises
quand ils sont arrivés pardon mais il
était dans le premier 1 % pas le premier
2 pour change pas le premier 5% le 1er
1% en maths et en physique donc nous
avions et nous avons toujours une
excellence dans ce domaine peut être
qu'elle est contestable aujourd'hui mais
ses talents la soie et sont bien
supérieurs à ce qui existe dans d'autres
pays
nous avons souffert de quoi il nous
souffrons de quoi le premier point nous
n'avons pas très pitot
c'est comme ça c'est ainsi nous ne
savons pas mobiliser des capitaux
le deuxième point sur le capital risque
nous avons une culture qui est risques
adverses comme diraient les américains
je vais m'expliquer là dessus ça il ya
des films il ya des tas d'histoires qui
raconte cela vous avez quelqu'un qui
arrive à un moment donné dans une banque
qui explique son projet en france on lui
dit bon c'est quoi la garantie aux états
unis on lui dit qu'un jeu de prêter de
l'argent
huit fois sur dix sept fois sur dix y
perdent les banques
trois fois sur dix il gagne et il est
beaucoup
prenez l'exemple des fonds
d'investissement private equity aux
états unis dans la silicon valley et
vous demandez comment ça fonctionne et
si ça vous intéresse à l'occasion je
serais très heureux de vous ménager les
contacts et c'est comme ça sur 10
investissement il y en a un qui est
brillant généralement c'est pas un c'est
un sur cent plutôt peut-être même un sur
mille qui fait un facebook ou google a
un qui est brillant deux ou trois qui
sont bons voire très bons 5 qui sont
totalement déficitaire et puis un ou
deux qui sont moyens voilà c'est à peu
près comme ça que ça se passe
et il ya cette culture du risque nous
nous avons une culture adverse au risque
et et c'est un problème culturel
français nous avons d'autres choses qui
sont excellentes
il se trouve que là dessus nous avons ce
problème là et pourquoi est ce que nous
avons ce problème parce que nous n'avons
pas assez de capitaux nous aurions plus
de capitaux ce serait plus facile et je
vais encore
soulignait un point qui me paraît
important puisqu'il s'agit de public
j'ai eu à la suite de l'économie de ce
rapport j'ai eu l'idée de créer un fonds
dédié disant il faut absolument alors
j'ai d'abord essayé de convaincre des
gens on dira écoutez faite le c'est pas
mon métier je suis pas un financier etc
et donc je suis allé voir beaucoup de
financiers pour le redis je pense que
c'est quelque chose d'intéressant je
pense que c'est porteur d'avenir et je
pense que vous avez intérêt à le faire
je n'ai pas été entendu je n'étais
probablement pas et c'est bon pour
défendre le dossier et je suis prêt à le
croire alors je j'ai dit très bien dans
ce cas je vais faire et je suis allé
voir et didier lombard et stéphane
richard puisque dans la situation où il
a été président le directeur général joe
a exposé l'idée
ils ont dit tout de suite oui mais est
infiniment en disant c'est une bonne
idée
faisons le et nous l'avons fait et nous
avons une équipe
nous avons d'ailleurs investi dans une
structure spécifique de manière à ce que
soient totalement déconnecté de publicis
et d'orange france télécom pour que ce
ne soit pas perturbée par les intérêts
de l'un ou de l'autre et c'est une
société indépendante dans lesquelles
nous avons 49% et et qui fait des
investissements avec 3 3 domaines ce
qu'on appelle pardon c'est comme ça que
ça se dit ça m'a anglais le early stage
donc c'est le début c'est pas tout à
fait à l'initiation de l'idée elle campe
l'idée est initié à ce moment là c'est
ce qu'on appelle les business angels qui
donne un peu tout ce que les américains
appellent friends and family et et puis
ensuite early stade c'est l'idée elle a
commencé à prendre forme ils ont eu de
quoi faire d'autres représentations le
début d'une idée et c'est à réunir
quelques coups que quelques associés et
là on donne de l'argent
ensuite il y a
la possibilité de faire un
investissement moyen de 2 à 3 millions
et puis après il ya ce qu'on appelle les
grosses et et là on peut faire des
investissements de 20 à 30 millions nous
nous avons mis 75 millions sur la table
france télécom-orange à 1075 mis sur la
table nous avons d'autres partenaires
qui vont mettre de l'argent sur la table
le fonds européen a mis une dizaine de
millions la caisse des dépôts veut
mettre probablement une dizaine de
millions mais je voudrais que d'autres
entreprises mettent des sommes
substantielles de façon à ce qu'on ait
un fonds de 500 ou 600 millions
susceptibles d'aider beaucoup de jeunes
startups parce que proportionnellement
nous avons certainement au moins autant
davantage qu israël dans ses dents dans
ce domaine et il faut savoir que par
tête d'habitant
israël est le premier pays au monde en
matière de dépôts de brevets et qu' ils
déposent plus de brevets et contribuer
davantage à la valeur ajoutée d'après ce
que disent les gens que ce soit google
que ce soit facebook que ce soit apple
où que ce soit microsoft ou intel ou
cisco vous écoutez les présidents ils
vous expliqueront que la filière qui a
été mise en oeuvre en israël qui partait
de rien il ya 15 ans c'était la taille
des diamants et ils ont mis en place
tout un système supportés par l'état
tout l'étude figure d'ailleurs dans le
rapport sur l'économie de l'immatériel
que nous avons fait et on explique très
bien comment est ce qu'on peut réaliser
cette opération
tout y est et c'est quelque chose qui
permet à ce moment-là de réussir un bon
développement là où je suis un peu moins
en accord avec vous si vous permettez
monsieur le sénateur c'est sur l'idée du
houx et je crois qu'on est plutôt dans
la relation et je crois qu'il faut
investir dans ce secteur est
investir prioritairement dans ce secteur
parce que c'est porteur d'avenir
mais je crois que nous devons tout faire
pour ré industrialisation et
réindustrialiser la france parce que de
toute façon nous sommes un pays de plus
de 60 millions d'habitants et que nous
n'aurons jamais une économie qui
reposera uniquement sur la brillance des
nouvelles technologies de la génétique
ou de toutes ces voies nouvelles de
développement et qu'il nous faut donc
trouver les moyens d'avoir une assise
industrielle fort à ce sujet je dois
souligner parce que je trouve que c'est
important même si des fois ce nom ne
doit pas être prononcée facilement mais
en 1993 avec gréement h lévy qui était à
l'époque était encore président de
renault et dominique strauss kahn qui
terminait ses fonctions au ministère de
l'industrie
nous avons créé le cercle de l'industrie
et dont l'objet était de développer
l'image de l'industrie en france de la
défendre auprès de bruxelles et de faire
en sorte que l'industrie soit un peu
mieux apprécier je vais vous confier
juste papa non pas dans d'accord on est
d'accord alors pardon on est d'accord je
vais juste faire une anecdote si vous le
permettez parce qu'une fois encore on
voit bien la culture
nous avons voulu faire une opération
avec des entreprises qui faisait une
opération portes ouvertes et qui en même
temps faisait une exposition à et un
débat au carrousel du louvre et nous
avons voulu avoir des élèves et nous
voulions des élèves d'université des
étudiants nous voulons des élèves de
grandes écoles encore des étudiants et
nous voulions des élèves des lycées et
de collèges y compris le collège
technique bien sûr
le drame le temps perdu plus d'un an de
négociations avec des instituteurs des
professeurs l'éducation nationale qui ne
voulait pas lâcher leurs enfants et
qu'ils ne voulaient pas venir avec
rencontrer des entreprises depuis les
choses ont changé depuis beaucoup de
choses ont changé ça s'est nettement
améliorée je tiens à le dire mais
c'était incroyable nous étions la peste
c'était totalement tabou il devenir
oser dire écoutez ce serait bien que ces
jeunes têtes viennent dans toute leur
diversité rencontré des patrons voient
ce que c'est que l'industrie et visiter
des usines visiter des stands et essayer
d'avoir un dialogue mais alors on a on a
fini par réussir et ceci grâce à coin à
l'intervention de dominique strauss kahn
qui a fait il était plus ministre
je cliquais vraiment manière massive il
est intervenu et nous avons eu des
classes entières qui sont venus
essentiellement de collèges techniques
mais quelquefois deux collèges et de
lycées et et les enfants étaient c'était
formidable
il était heureux comme tout oui je
reconnais je le dit pas assez vite pas
autant qu'on aimerait mais il ya des
progrès très sensible quand été fait
pardon je m'enflamme un peu mais l'homme
ce biais c'est très intéressant
merci monsieur le président est ce que
je peux me permettre de poser une
question trop pouvez vous nous indiquer
combien d'entités recouvre les 98
entreprises que vous représentez comme
il y en a t'il en phrases comme il y en
a t'il à l'étranger et les évolutions
aujourd'hui traduisent l ame progrès de
l'interdire l'internaute internalisation
pardon des chaînes de valeur
avez vous une idée du poids de la
variable fiscale dans ce processus
alors là ma réponse et je sais pas je ne
sais pas alors je peux vous dire deux ou
trois choses pour eux et on peut essayer
de vous donner des informations et vous
faire une réponse écrite je parle sous
le contrôle de stéphane robert qui est
ici présentes 97 98 entreprises
il y en a je fais des bêtises seulement
7,8 peut-être une dizaine je n'ai pas le
décompte en tête qui ont leur siège
ailleurs qu'en france le tout le reste
ce sont des sièges français
donc voilà ensuite comment se répartit
la valeur comment se répartit les
filiales comment est-ce qu'elle
fonctionne et c'est quelle est la valeur
ajoutée transférer pas transféré je suis
dans le bleu le plus total je ne sais
rien mais rien je sais pour publicis
comment ça fonctionne je peux vous le
dire en ce qui concerne publicis nous
avons un peu plus je vous ai dit qu'on
était dans 80 pays en propre 80 85
et 109 pays au total nous avons un peu
plus de 1000 centres de profits un peu
plus de 700 entité légale
nous avons plus d'une centaine d'entités
dans lesquels il y a encore des
participations d'individus locaux qui
nous en vendu leurs affaires et qui
restent associés et donc nous nous avons
les activités qui se déroulent
localement et ses entreprises locales
payent au groupe deux choses des
prestations de management vise et donc
le concours qu'on apporte c'est tout ce
que l'on fait et ce qu'on appelle des
coordinations fise qui sont pour des
clients alors ça dépend où les clients
sont installés près des clients il y a
un un centre de coordination et nous
assurons que la stratégie du client est
bien suivie partout nous avons des
équipes qui sont basés à paris et ses
équipes sont facturés partout dans le
monde
voilà comment est ce que nous
fonctionnons et tout est hyper documenté
tout est hyper clair et il est nous
sommes soumis à des contrôles fiscaux
épouvantail dans tous les pays parce que
tout ce que nous facturons dans un pays
est d'emblée et quasi automatiquement
contestées à partir du moment où ça
s'appelle management fise où ça
s'appelle codina jeune fille s'appelle
quoi que ce soit honoraires de je ne
sais pas quoi de support ou de
prestations et instantanément
nous avons des questions de la part du
fisc locale qui nous dit mais attendez
est ce que ce n'est pas quelque chose
pour
prélever de la substance qui a été
générée dans ce pays et pour échapper à
l'impôt local
voilà et donc nous documentons tout ça
de manière extrêmement rigoureuse je
pense d'ailleurs que pour les très
grandes entreprises celles qui ont une
collaboration internationale
elles sont toutes force est d'avoir une
documentation extraordinairement précise
quand il s'agit des transferts quand il
s'agit des prix transfert pour la
technologie la matière première des
travaux intermédiaires etc
mais une petite précision dans un
interview que vous avez donnée au mois
d'avril
donc je pense pourtant que président de
l'afep vous parlez 250 entreprises qui
représentent 27 % des emplois oui 34 %
de la valeur ajoutée 53 % des
exportations et 62 % de la recherche et
développement
ça ce sont les entreprises adhérentes de
la fait pour vous parler des 250
entreprises françaises je suis ce que je
suis française et ses chiffres et douce
et ont ils sont très forts comme
chiffres oui et là dessus j'avais donné
tout à l'heure des chiffres légèrement
différent voilà danseuse wynn ccd son
sims est dans les chiffres que j'ai
donné tout à l'heure ce sont des sources
insee
est ce dangereux sont des des sources
qui sont c'est pour ça que je me suis
basé sur son information cela alors que
là ce sont des sources que nous avons
recueillies nous mêmes aux prêts à faire
bon vous évoquez vous en avez parlé tout
à l'heure comme étant peut-être la
première priorité la convergence
européenne au moins je vois pas des
etats-unis ou du japon d'autres ou des
brics ou par la convergence européenne
il ya un exemple le dessus que vous vous
exposez à taxe sur le chiffre d'affaires
institué par gordon brown est abandonnée
puis vous avez parlé du déplacement à
dublin des orientations à automatiser
oui alors c'est un inconvénient pour moi
d'être absent c'est le président
ok dans le détail on a donné par médéa
et comment ça s'est passé
compte tenu des perspectives évidemment
c'était important et si vous en avez
parlé je passe sauf si vous avez des
questions complémentaires mais on avait
monsieur rapporteur monsieur le
président pardon oui j'espère monsieur
lévy bhl n'ai pas eu le sentiment d'être
soumis à la question dans cette
commission de cette vénérable assemblée
notre souci comprenez le bien c'est la
transparence bien évidemment la
compréhension des situations et la
recherche de capitaux est fine et vous
dites il manque des capitaux nous en
cherchons nous mène c'est le but ultime
de cette de ce travail que nous menons
pour la formation l'économie
l'équipement les infrastructures
effectivement il faut de l'argent pour
l'économie réelle c'est évident et
autres remarques incidente si le nombre
de contribuables diminue c'est peut-être
aussi un signe de la paupérisation d'une
certaine catégorie population en france
vous savez comme nous plusieurs millions
de nos concitoyens sont passés sous le
seuil de pauvreté est donc peut-être un
lien de cause à effet aussi mais je
voulais vous terminez avec une citation
que j'ai lu ce matin dans la presse d'un
institut dont j'ai oublié le nom je
crois que c'est alpha live mais sous
réserve de vérification à l'occasion des
nominations dans les comptes
administrations des grands groupes qui
ont lieu en ce moment
l'institut souligné le fait que de
nombreux membres figurait dans plusieurs
comptes administrations et faisait ce
commentaire
en france on est des champions de la
financiarisation des conseils
d'administration les administrateurs
sont de plus en plus de pure financiers
fin de citation alors après vous avoir
entendu parler de l'activité réelle
d'économie réelle d'industrie j'ai
l'impression que vous serez d'accord
avec cette vie
qu'en pensez vous je n'ai pas lu donc je
ne sais pas il y a je veux faire un
commentaire là dessus
de manière générale premièrement il ya
une nette amélioration dans la
composition des conseils
d'administration depuis une dizaine
d'années il y avait et c'était un
reliquat du système des noyaux durs il y
avait un système de barbichette qui
existait c'était je rentre dans ton
conseil tu rentres dans mon cou ça y est
je prend 2% que la société tu prend 2%
de la mienne s'était ainsi que comme il
n'y avait pas d'argent que le système de
privatisation avait été montée pour
éviter justement que les entreprises
soient pris sous le contrôle étranger ce
système a eu savait sa vertu qui a été
de faire en sorte que ces grandes
entreprises françaises ne passe pas à
l'exception notable d'une qui est
pechiney sur le contrôle étranger de
manière générale quand on regarde ce qui
s'est passé il ya eu des investissements
il ya eu des fusions en france mais il
ya peu d'entreprises françaises qui ont
été reprises parmi les grandes par des
étrangers il ya exception notable de
pechiney et donc ça a bien fonctionné
tout doucement
le système n'a plus lieu d'être et
on est dans un système classique mais il
en existe aux états unis où les sociétés
ne sont pas contrôlés et que la seule
chose qui les protège pour l'instant
c'est d'avoir accès à des capitaux quand
ils peuvent et d'être bien tenu par un
conseil alors quand il s'agit des
conseils d'administration il ya
effectivement pas mal de financer dans
les conseils
pourquoi première chose c'est que on vit
dans un monde qui est de plus en plus
compliqué quand on veut faire certaines
opérations financières qu'on reprenait
les convertibles
j'en ai fait je savais pas ce que
c'était donc j'avoue à quel point
j'étais ignorant de cet aspect
heureusement que au sein du conseil on
m'a expliqué attention voilà un peu
comment ça se passe
voilà il faut faire un appel d'offres il
faut faire très à il faut vérifier ces
points il faut avoir un point juridique
très précis et c'est donc comme on est
dans un système de financiarisation de
l'économie
avoir des gens qui connaissent bien le
sujet ce n'est pas plus mal
ce qu'il ne faut pas c'est bien entendu
que les conseils soient dominées par les
financiers ça c'est clair
et je ne connais pas la composition de
tous les conseils mais je pense que
comme je le disais tout à l'heure on a
fait beaucoup d'efforts et beaucoup de
progrès l'autre progrès que nous avons
faits et là je dois dire que le c'est à
la suite
de mon arrivée à la fête pardon d'être
un peu personnel mais nous avons pris
une initiative qui étaient concurrentes
n'ont pas en concurrence mais
concurremment de celle de du projet copé
zimmermann de féminisation des conseils
et ça ça a été très utile parce que dans
la féminisation des conseils on est allé
chercher des des femmes ailleurs et au
sein de la fête nous avons mis au point
un système ça s'est fait avant moi et
qui est un système très intéressant de
mentor et de mendy et donc il y a des
potentiels des femmes qui sont
susceptibles de devenir demain manque de
conseils qui sont prises en charge par
lé des chefs d'entreprises qui lé mentor
pendant un certain temps et qui ensuite
les parraine pour rejoindre des des
conseils d'administration et là il ya
quand même
sas a provoqué deux choses
rajeunissement
ce qui n'est pas plus mal je sais que si
je disais ça aux états unis je serait
passible d'un procès en discrimination
je le précise parce que j'ai eu ce
procès sur le dos dans une cave et dit
il il faudrait songer à rajeunir
j'ai eu immédiatement un procès
rajeunissement et diversification
je pensais on a assisté une autre mais
moi j'ai constaté que le sénat s'était
largement rajeuni et féminisé et un peu
mais largement rajeunie 50% à publicis
me dernier 5 50% 50% et nous avons été
il ya trois semaines de cela nous avons
reçu un prix aux etats-unis nous sommes
dans les ce qu'on appelle les fortunes
five hundred la société au conseil
d'administration le plus féminisé et je
dois vous dire que ça s'arrête pas là
quarante deux pour cent du management
je parle du top management de nos
agences et féminin s'est enregistrée moi
moi j'ai entendu un mois j'ai entendu
mais je ne capterait pas rappeler le
questionnaire monsieur le président si
vous pouviez répondre aux dernières
questions qui n'ont pas été évoquées au
sein de bien mieux
nous cherchons à apporter un merci
monsieur le président merci je vais
train dans la présidence à votre
président titulaire
si la voilà dans le rang comme merci
merci mesdames et messieurs de votre
patience et pardon si par moments vous
avez eu le sentiment que je je m'étais
un peu de chaleur dans mon exposé
merci c'est la fin de l'audition de
maurice lévy par la commission d'
enquête sénatoriale sur l'évasion
fiscale pour en savoir plus ou pour
revoir cette audition notre site
internet publicsenat.fr
prochain rendez vous avec les travaux
parlementaires c'est cet après midi à
partir de 15h avec cette fois les
travaux de la délégation sénatoriale à
l'outre-mer qui entend patrick romero le
pdg de shell sur la prospection
pétrolière en guyane bonne fin de
journée à tous